if we are talking about
say if you wrote in one of you
reason is the only possible barrier
against barbarism fanaticism and
stupidity that's a big statement reason
is the only barrier against barbarism
fanaticism a stupid why is that you're
putting all your card or reason well
first of all I want to tell you rub that
it's much easier to ask the questions
you are asking that to give an answer
but yes I think absolutely that all our
rights our liberties right of man
justice all these are inventions of
reason or this does not exist in nature
we invented all this in order to give a
meaning to our life and to organize a
decent society so reason is really the
Alpha and Omega you know civilized
society is a society which places and
faces on what unites people and modular
idea and what unites people is where
settles as reasonable being is rational
beings people who are rational and
consequently diet and equal as a concert
or as russo has put it rational beings
were able to create their own world the
world in which believe it started in the
70 century we observe in fact with the
father of liberalism hubs and clock but
in the 18th century be enlightenment
has given all this proportion of
enormous revolution with tremendous
evolution and I am speaking of
enlightenment I am NOT speaking of the
age of the Enlightenment I love speaking
on the 18th century and Here I am
following Sorel and Spangler for whom
enlightenment was a form of civilization
it was a concept a framework of a
civilization and the Enlightenment could
be Italian enlightenment with Chinese
enlightenment or the European like me in
the int'l century as such a--such the
indictment based on the rationality of
human beings gives us the capability to
build our own where can i interfere I
mean is rationalism directly linked to
civilization I think a rational being or
human beings seems to be for me an
illusion evolution illusion eosin as as
for human being we are not only driven
by our intellect we are driven by our
passions but our beliefs but our values
so as being we are a multidimensional
dimensional beings not only do we do
things because we are thinking or
because we are rational most of our
deeds are being made we are making
history most of it through passions even
the concept of national States did not
come after a analytical thinking which
has pushed humanity or Europeans to
create national state it was rather
through passions through poets and
through
writers of novels it was a dream which
has been which which became part of
history and this dream actually is is
more powerful than rationalism I think
we need to treat ourselves as
multi-dimensional beings we do things we
do we make history not only through our
strengths but we also make things
through our weaknesses that's what
differentiate the human nature of the
human being from our other creatures I
save made a very important statement
that he says well you know our moral
failures can only be grounded in reason
that's the only thing that that has a
universal value so if you question his
inside there can only be reason then in
what according to you are our moral
values grounded I'm not putting a
contradiction between reason and values
or passions these are not they do not
come in contradiction but they do come
as a package together however if we put
reason as if you are in laboratoire how
to say it in English laboratory outside
of our everyday life then it's not
reason it's like a calculated zero and
once only but that's not a human being
that's not what drives us to think
that's not what drives us there is
beside reason what we call wisdom so you
can have a person who is really rational
but he has no wisdom so he will use his
reason in evil ways so but wisdom what
is it it's not is it only rationalist
its experience it's our history it's our
memory it's our feelings our family it's
our it's all of us all what makes us
human so
but I think that the more concrete
question then is for your concept of
being civilized and and moral values do
you need a concept of a god yes or no of
God yeah i think yes we do need the
concept of God so there is a big
difference what what stan helsing look
because the beliefs are part of our
rationale I don't understand I mean in
any cases we need to start from a belief
we need to start from for example that
we do exist otherwise if we do not
believe that we do exist and that we are
capable of thinking then we cannot
proceed into doing things into even
thinking I mean this is what the card
was trying to do too so beliefs are part
of our rationals and what the cart has
done actually is that he's called God as
guarantor for his belief otherwise he
would go to the Eternity into into his
skepticism so I think yes God is part of
our rational and it is maybe a condition
for that rationalism so you're right it
is the Enlightenment it's the idea that
we have rights and values and that we
then respect each other and if you have
to you enforce it by the rule of law or
the gun sometimes it takes violence to
get people to come around it took a
civil war and seven hundred thousand
dead in America to put it into slavery
sometimes that's what it takes it'd be
better if we didn't we're all in the
education business and the idea of
business if we could just write and
convince Isis that they shouldn't do do
this that's not going to happen the aim
is this morning was right you know in
the long run we need the moderate
Muslims to to rein in the extremists but
the idea that the problem is extremism
or extreme religion is also not true the
jains are extremists they they don't
want to kill even bugs but I'm not
worried about the Jains coming to my
house and the Mormons you know have all
kinds of wacky beliefs as do
Scientologists but I'm not worried about
them it's the belief that the creator of
the universe wrote a book and he's
omniscient and
the right answers are in the book and
all you got to do is memorize them and
anybody that doesn't see that is wrong
and therefore must be brought to bear
under it or killed that's the problem no
come on the 12 I know nobody by the time
by the end of the 20th century after the
experience of fascism and communism it's
perfectly clear that both secular
civilizations and religious
civilizations can commit enormous across
a god or ideology but Marxism is a full
religion you can deny that there's an
absolute truth that that bit that you
can know that and they were wrong and
and that has also declined the number of
states that do that so if i can give 11
last data i can show one last dataset
because terrorism is the elephant in the
room the number of terrorist attacks is
declined dramatically have one more
little graph here to show you this is
from Erica Chenoweth and her data set
she crunched every terrorist attack
every attempt at violent revolution from
1900 to you know few years ago and the
numbers of those that succeed that are
nonviolent are three times more likely
than violent and the number of those
that are violent attempts of violent
revolution are four times more likely to
fail and the rates on the bottom graph
there are the nonviolent ones are
becoming more popular in other words and
the number of states that terrorist
groups have overturned zero they almost
never achieve their political goal tell
it to tell it to Paris I mean they're
not going to talk you think they're
gonna overturn no no no what I need is
not i'm not sure that you can
quantitatively define our moral
condition i think what i am it's good
news i just did I understand but I think
that even a single massacre or a single
ethnic cleansing or a single genocide is
an intolerable stain on a civilization
but we're never gonna get to zero I'm
never going to be zero we're not but
they were never in any danger get it
video if it's that we can't get to zero
so we shouldn't try to make two steps
forward and one step back then then of
course there's no point in trying but
we've been doing this for five hundred
years and it's working the enlightenment
values of science and reason are really
better than all the other attempts
you